that's nice
so you're that's like Eric when he
drives home just singing the [ __ ] you
sing [ __ ] by yourself yeah that's how it
sounds I have I play karaoke in my car
pretty lit actually you know on the
screen the words come up you know what I
mean I'm just like Unbreak My Heart say
you love me again
just [ __ ]
um
you ever met this guy oh I'm the Dumber
you can't argue there's something about
me you have no idea
[Music]
I don't know maybe maybe in the 80s this
was the 80s right this was so 80s he's
very 40 16 here
he's very 80s for sure 100 I mean he
looks like he like either 80s or 2022.
like a tooth the guy well I mean you
know he went to the Met Gala all right
we started right yeah we started yeah
um have you seen did you see Jared Leto
I didn't I guess I did with the Gucci
guy what the [ __ ] is this that's Jared
Leto that's Jared Leto yeah at the Met
Gala have y'all met these nuts son
that's what I wanted Oh I thought that
he just wore a suit
are you sure that's shared letter that
is Jared Leto yeah
yeah yeah just be known for acting yeah
yeah sure he looks like a peacock yeah
I mean there's a lot going on there man
okay it's got to be so dangerous check
this out imagine you're at the Met Gala
and you're over at the bar getting a
drink and this motherfucker's standing
there like that how do you have just a
normal conversation with a dude like a
guy out how do you get your eyes safe
yeah I know where you get a straw from
first of all
and second of all I look
he's an artiste man he comes out there
that's what he is bro he'll wear the
damn silverware drawer to them to the
mall you know that's how he does it that
doesn't look like him to me yeah can you
zoom in his face
he looks like he's got a mask on too he
looks like Gary Oldman oh he does look
like Gary Oldman
what's wrong with me oh those are I mean
this is like a Fifth Element Jerry
Oldman yeah yeah yeah
no that's Jared Leto she is but yeah I
guess I mean it is him but like
wow that's so annoying imagine just like
having to be with him and be like all
right let's go oh God like we're
watching out friendship like imagine
just getting ready with that you know
yeah yeah or having him get in the car
and you just set him in the trunk yeah
how to get there yeah so and he shows up
so
yeah how did he get what would his name
be if he was a co-host on the podcast
oh God so it's King the tin wing and the
what
poll question and the [ __ ] no who
knows man that's bad but the other
outfit was good the one that he dressed
with the Gucci guy on the left right
there yeah no you had it right there
right there left there you go that's
cool I mean that's pushing it but it's
cool why are y'all looking at these
man's clothing bro that's what we do
baby it's like it's like he almost had
it but then he has a purse yeah the
person's bad yeah that's cool though but
where are you gonna keep your stuff bro
yeah that what like what if you don't
have no pockets see that's the problem
is if a pant doesn't have a pocket on it
it should come with those Hot Pockets
what about these I will [ __ ] keep
yourself yeah you can hang your keys on
any of those
hooks he got his house keys right here
he got his mail key over here
yeah man that's just that new age
janitor baby dude I remember remember
when Jay you ever walked behind the
janitor at school and he had all those
keys on him and it always just blew your
mind you were like how do you know where
all the keys go it's like having
passwords oh it was crazy that's why
every janitor was there for [ __ ]
years and years and years they had to be
there so they could learn the keys yeah
man that's crazy look at that oh and now
everything's just [ __ ] or fingerprint
how do you know all the kids like it's
just like that's why he's that old that
was the [ __ ] day that he finally knew
all the keys he held him up he's there
yeah see no no how many janitors [ __ ]
their pants because they didn't get the
the bathroom key like they got [ __ ] and
they're just like Punk they didn't get
it right oh [ __ ] well janitor's armor
one time we I was walking in the hall by
uh behind two like uh serve not like
kind of helperman at the schools
janitors or helper man and they one of
them said the other one he's like hey we
got to get the chairs put up in the gym
um
Mr Grant is speaking
and the guy goes Ulysses S Grant and he
goes [ __ ] no Mr Grant the science
teacher yeah and it was a real
conversation like the dude thought that
unless he's asked Grant was going to
speak at our school you ulyssa says
Grant I know the long dead was dead I
know did you know then too yeah yeah and
so everyone laughed at him no I was the
only one that heard it it was just them
two walking in the hall and I was behind
them am I wrong I was like hey we need
to get the chairs put up Mr Grant
speaking he's like Ulysses Grant he's
like Mr Grant the [ __ ] science yeah
and you Missy's Grant ironically is
Theo's father yeah
sorry if my dad was a general dog and
yells dad ain't [ __ ] your dad was just
general but look
General mail yeah General mail sounds
like a male catalog doesn't it I'm sure
it is General mail yeah I'm sure it is
um yeah one time I saw a guy uh uh what
do you what we call him uh janitors and
they were he was cleaning up this
[ __ ] pain I don't know why I said who
did that and he turned around and he
said [ __ ] that too I think about
that all the time dude I think about it
all the time and I felt so bad for that
dude he was right out was he a 1930s
actor no I know that's what a [ __ ]
see that's what it was like he was in a
play [ __ ] dude
tougher generous tall is a tall goes
with janitor if you're a tall gym yeah
yeah yeah I guess you gotta be because
you got to reach [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
that long broom that paint was high yeah
you can't have like Brad Williams be a
the janitor then you can't get anything
else yeah
we had a little janitor at uh my I had a
my niece's kindergarten had a little
janitor there and he would literally
push the vacuum with his shoulder bruh
he would uh like get the vacuum thing
going it was an upright and he would
push it with his shoulder like a
football player hitting one of those he
was small huh yeah a little small
designer yeah and he would just be like
oh wow pull up them uh ball pad things
and he would do the sweep the vacuuming
like this
oh man well Oh Me Oh man you you took it
to a hole that's how it would be it was
just real [ __ ] this is a real story
maybe yeah so how did he vacuum then if
he was pushing the vacuum huh
like this no he would push it like
pushes back against it like this no see
okay now he's going to hell too
[Laughter]
he got cut Corners sometimes yeah it was
like that yeah yeah like that sag back
football tackle sled tackle sled there
you go all right well what do we got
here what do you mean this is it man
speaking of janitors is this guy janitor
first of all does I feel like this
beautiful guy definitely uh has sent in
a video before has he really
probably I I don't recognize them but I
don't you guys got a lot of repeats
that's nice you're loyal fans hey what's
up guys Brennan Theo Chris Eric good
question everybody else in the studio
what's going on my name is Devin from
Canada and I have a debate club for you
guys today so let me lead you into the
story okay I used to work security at
the checkpoint in the Calgary Airport
and on two different occasions I
actually met Chris and Theo because they
were coming through that checkpoint and
I stopped and talked to both you guys
because the night before I was at both
of your shows now when Theo came through
he walked through the metal detector and
you know your boy lit that thing up so I
had to ask Theo whether or not he wanted
the body scan or a pat down now Theo he
chose the pat down wow of course even
the pat down and lucky for him it was me
doing it so I let your man go and it was
all good but the bay club is this when
you guys go through that airport are you
picking the body scan or a pat down
he needed some intimacy first of all
what set it off in the first place was
the two straps I won over this [ __ ]
club that's why you wanted the path you
wanted you wanted to give him something
and because of that so second of all the
thing that uh I like the pat down
because I don't trust the Machinery I
would rather get the hands on I would
rather know if something's going on or
not and have somebody know than the
machine like if you secretly brought a
bomb yeah or you're trying to get like a
a ball exam or something like what do
you mean something's going on what is he
gonna find on you and that's the guy I'm
talking about oh we know what if
somebody put something on you right like
you somebody snuck up or somebody you
know if a uh what is it called somebody
from another country who's doing crime
here what is that called
a terrorist terrorist yeah yeah does put
something on you they snuck a blade in
your jacket or they put a thing of uh
you want to know yeah well I want
somebody to [ __ ] know so if you're on
the plane yeah we are if you're on the
plane and all of a sudden you notice
because you went through the [ __ ]
body scan and not a pat down that you've
got a razor on you by mistake and
somebody put it there you you do what
hijack the plane no no you just chill
with the radio I don't know how this got
here so what the [ __ ] you need a pat
down for I don't think also human error
is way way more uh prevalent than the
[ __ ]
that thing but that thing what's it
doing you want yeah you're scared it's
because you're scared it's okay if it's
fear if you think it's because of
radiation
well here's another thing I will say
this that the thing is that the the
scanner here's what the scanner should
do is give you a [ __ ] MRI you're
already there it should give you some
information I told you he was looking
for some [ __ ] ghetto medical
treatment
he's like can y'all check and see if I
got enough of my products I'm gonna have
to do an MRI anyways at some point so
why don't you just [ __ ] I'm gonna get
the radiation do it now yeah you want an
extra [ __ ] and then he wants a printout
like after the thing so I use that print
out so when he's patting you down you
just say and would you feel for
testicular cancer right yeah yeah well
here's what they should do is the the
old trick is tell them something's in
your ass and they go look in there for
you bro nice and then they don't find
anything and you're off the hook and
they're the weirdo they've been looking
and yeah okay fair enough yeah you play
by the rules and if there's something
yeah you got to look in my ass you know
just told me Theo does not have medical
insurance well I'm just saying you can
say I took a nap upstairs on the second
level of the airport for an hour I woke
up it feels like something's in my ass
but if you told him that
um you know how they say don't leave
your luggage yeah yeah tell Theo don't
leave your ass always be awake always be
awake because you're asking about yeah
sleep with one ass closed baby that's my
motto and that's pretty much 100 of your
ass is closed
let's take a little break fellas because
the boys are on the road what are we
talking about man where are you gonna be
dude I'm glad you asked dude I'm in
Philly next week Thursday Friday
Saturday I'm in Philadelphia Sun at the
helium May 19th through the 21st I am
there and then I'm uh shopping friends
one night at the Hollywood improv some
people see on camera right now we'll be
there that's one night only May 25th and
then Portland Oregon June 9th through
the 11th and then San Francisco Cobbs my
one of my favorite clubs June 17th
through the 18th that's a fun one but
Philly you're up next come get some
stickboy.com for tickets you know what
you can do is go to Hollywood California
May 25th and go to Brendan's shop and
Friends
and then stay for the crystallia and
friends yeah
might see both of them you might see
both of us both times you
know you're both times yeah May 25th
Hollywood California but uh my tour tour
is uh me going on on Tori's uh Atlanta
Georgia I'll be there September 9th
September 10th Washington DC uh I'm
doing Stockton Oakland Peoria Rockford
Illinois Raleigh Denver big one Bellco
theater November 5th Cheyenne Wyoming
and then Boston which I'm excited about
I love Boston November 12th at
Jacksonville Florida
chrysalia.com chrisley.com chrisley.com
what'd you say don't even just take that
off the screen you know what I mean it's
not even right but I'm gonna do that
right you do that yeah yeah
but I'm gonna be uh and in the Dania
Beach Improv it's a new improv I just
picked up the game it's fun yeah this
weekend so this today if you're watching
this today so Friday and Saturday come
check me out and uh there and then um
you know Creed from uh uh with arms open
no no not that crazy the Creed from the
office the old guy he's actually a great
musician I'm gonna be with him at the
mint on the oh yeah I saw you post about
that yeah I'm gonna be with him on the
mint yeah first he's singing and I'm
gonna do comedy to open up he does like
some kind of comedy thing so really
funny guys later that's what he goes by
so come check by Daniel Beach man you
come go see Eric today yeah tomorrow
today tomorrow yeah Saturday come check
out fun sounds good yeah nobody in this
room has a problem they're locked out
but still what are we talking about here
baby dude listen I told you my crowd is
a real wiener Fest and I see a lot of
these guys of the meet and greets are
losing your hair here's a little fact
you're seeing a lot of forehead in the
beginning of this of the shows you're
looking at a lot of foreheads they could
really benefit from what could they
benefit from keeps man and don't feel
lonely because more than 50 million Bros
in the U.S suffer from male pattern ball
discs keeps offers a simple affordable
stress-free way to keep your freaking
hair man 24 7 care and support it's low
cost ten dollars a month that's it ten
dollars ten dollars yes I would think it
would least be at least be 40 Grand a
month me too that's what I thought
unbelievable that's how important it is
how important is your hair keeps has
everything you're here needs delivered
straight to your door also look for me
prevention is key do you know what I
mean I've got a big forehead if that
keeps going back and back and back I am
in serious trouble why they call it
keeps yes because you're here remember
prevention is key trippings can take
four to six months see results so act
right now if you're ready to take action
prevent hair loss go to keeps.com
k-a-t-s that's k-e-e-p-s.com cats to
receive your first month of treatment
free that's keeps.com cats to get your
first month free ke eps.com k-a-t-s
hey Chris I know you're I know you're a
big NBA fan yeah you're a big Sports guy
but here's the deal though I'm a fan of
things and I like things and this is a
thing and then also betting I'm in
because you in order to get things you
need money and if you like basketball
and you want to make money you gotta use
DraftKings Sports books the official
Sportsman part of the NBA this week new
customer can bet just five dollars on
any team so okay so if you could bet
five dollars what are you gonna win
you're gonna win six dollars dude dude
what you bet five dollars on any team to
win ten dollars one hundred and fifty
dollars in free bets yo what nachos they
got parties DraftKings yeah dude you got
drafted this is a d this is a steal dude
it's nuts okay well if you're looking at
so if you're telling me if you're
looking to turn a small bet into a big
payday during the NBA Playoffs you can
do that with DraftKings yep dude same
game parlays you can just do just that
just that create your own parlay by
combining multiple bets like which team
will win total threes made total
rebounds and more and boom you have a
shot at even bigger payout right now all
customers can place the same game parlay
with three or more legs and get a free
BET back up to 25 if one leg doesn't hit
wow download the DraftKings Sportsbook
app right now use promo code Kats cats
five dollars on any NBA team to win
their game between like six bucks or
what dude and get 150 in free bets if
they what
150. I like your excitement okay yeah
yeah yeah yeah this promo code Kats only
at draftking Sportsbook minimum age
eligibility restrictions apply C show
notes for details see next page for
directions for disclaimer here is a babe
right there
sting in the wing family
my name is Robin and I could really use
some relationship advice I'm 46 years
old
and
Men My Age don't like me I like them
they don't like me really hey mom so
basically my dating pool has just been a
bunch of 20 to 35 year olds who are you
know boldly hitting on me and don't seem
to give a crap about my age and I'm very
forthright with it I you know don't have
anything to hide but
um
yeah I don't get it why don't men my age
well even hit on me help me they want
that monkey baby that's what I'm saying
buzz buzz
are they uh are they uh intimidated by
her I mean maybe like the younger
Village this is this Y'all Gonna not be
100 okay oh no yeah no what is it what
is it are you saying no no hold on a
second are you saying because the older
dudes are looking for younger women
talking yeah yeah I know but bro she's
hot I know but and if you want to like
be with somebody and you're older here
check this out if you are
it's let's say you're 46 47 48 year old
50 year old guy and let's say you want
to get into a relationship yeah and you
want to have kids oh okay yeah well
definitely you maybe you don't want to
start with somebody 40. I understand
that but there's a lot of guys okay okay
I'm with you but now if you're somebody
that's like hey I've already been
married I had kids already and I just
want to be with somebody
then this is perfect but what the thing
is is like my question and it's not that
it's her fault I'm asking where is she
looking for well yeah that's definitely
these guys like where are you looking
are you looking online because a lot of
the guys will say oh he's interested in
you know she's what 46 they'll be like
20 to yeah 40. and then she's out and
she's forthcoming about her age which is
fine which is good of course but then
you're missing out on that category if
you're out at a bar then there's also
[ __ ] 25 26 year olds at the bar and
the [ __ ] 40 year old dudes are like
what's up
don't meet a guy at a bar anyway yeah so
like yeah I just my advice is wide in
your search to different places
different interests different uh look
for people that have similar interests
to you that are not just in the in this
like World of like online dating and all
that kind of stuff because those guys
are looking for yeah you know I feel
obviously a lot of people with this lady
probably just trying to plump that
monkey a little bit they're trying to
get up on them yum kettles baby you know
what I'm talking about I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry don't look at it yum
kettles tits I think what are you
talking about
do we have tits
yum kettles I like that I'm just saying
baby she got them real [ __ ] fluff
tonsils on her you know what I'm talking
okay I'm sorry fluff tonsils
can you use the answer can you use that
what is the origin of fluff tonsils
please can we get the cues out in a
sentence it originated as yam
yam kettles yeah okay this lady's
obviously sporting that kitchenware dog
you know what I'm talking about dude do
you do that when you [ __ ] yeah
that's actually kind of hot it's not bad
man it is what it is but I'll say this
do you think this lady is really having
a problem that's what I'm wondering yeah
I think so I think that she is looking
for a particular type of guy and she
wants to take somebody her age and then
like and then like yeah it's probably
fun to have some 30 year old old pound
those yum kettles right yeah but now but
she's looking for what you want see what
you want yeah she wants somebody she
could watch TV with and [ __ ] be like
remember Matlock you know what I mean
yeah
she wants to do that that's Law and
Order yeah yeah but yeah right right
right who's your favorite Batman and
they go together Adam West you know what
I mean they don't [ __ ] like Sean Connery
but what I'm saying is like so that
particular guy he's out there she's cute
hit her up I think she is cute man she's
obviously in Orange County she's in yeah
she's in somewhere nice yeah because
look you could tell by her hair she's
Rich bro and I'll say this also she is
in that age range where I think if
there's a lot of like pervy man at 60
they're looking for 25 32 year old and
if there's a lot of men that so she kind
of gets left out of that space I don't
know I just think uh you know you have
to just expand your base but I don't
believe that a man isn't trying to get
up is it trying to meet this lady that's
the part I don't believe she might mean
uh in a long term right that's what I
mean she's looking for like a long-term
relationship with a but you know you
have to just decide too is like you know
if you're you're some guy you're you
know you're if there's some wealthy
whatever guy right like what do you mean
like a count or something what is he
okay yeah it counts yeah like I guess
account want to deal with like whatever
that what what does that person want to
deal with you know I don't know it has
to be matching personalities I say to
her try like eHarmony or these kinds of
things where you have to like fill out a
questionnaire and like you know uh you
know
y'all sweating this lady too much I
would not I want her she's asking for
advice yeah she sent her video in asking
us for advice and you telling us we
sweating her we're doing too much yeah
no no you're not even really helping
that much man you just said she had yum
kettles and Club bonkers
she's done mating well look baby she got
did she say that yeah she's got 25 year
olds all the time she got them slam
hampers on her freaking chest
slam hampers the woman doesn't even make
sense he's gonna lock y'all up in my
nuts you little [ __ ] let's roll bro
she's gonna be fine I'll see you at the
mall like we got Robbie Malek yeah
what's up guys I got a relationship
advice question here what if it was
being accused to be in Rami Malek
what do you do if
you are vehemently trying to convince
your friends
come out
a little bit unusual because about my
mother
um not dating my mother I'm from the
Northeast so what if that was his mom
but
um
she's a bit of a booze bag and I still
live at home and I moved back home
recently after a couple years away to
save some money for when the world tanks
uh my fiance and I can slide in buy a
home at a cheap price so I'm just saving
up a little extra but uh her drinking's
worse than worse than ever probably and
she's getting bundled nowadays she's
getting absolutely shit-faced yeah it
doesn't stop at one glass but one glass
and she's just full three and I can't
get through to her she seems like she
kind of wants to get better but doesn't
really and I'm just [ __ ] sick of it
okay I'm at the point where do I say
[ __ ] it and may or may not have a
grandmother for my children or do I like
start being a dick and I'm like hey I'm
gonna throw your wine out in the woods
here like I don't know what to do at
this point so gang gang buzz buzz Flint
flap
this tough guy that made me [ __ ] tear
up dude yeah really did your mom drink
no no
It's just tough man it's like [ __ ] yeah
It's just tough man because you [ __ ]
lose your your family off this [ __ ] and
it's just brutal man yeah just
I feel for you man I feel for your mom
too it's [ __ ] rough
and what do you feel like is rough about
it man I mean I feel I hear you I'm just
thinking about it with you
I mean he can't control her behavior you
know he he can't try and help her he can
only there comes to a point where the
only thing he can do
is
let her [ __ ] up and then she hasn't
figured out herself you know and I mean
I've met so many of these [ __ ] people
yeah me too and that's a hard thing to
do when it's a loved one because what
you end up doing is enabling their
behavior and when you enable their
behavior it only makes it worse and then
it's hard when people say it's so easy
just to be like you know you have to let
them hit rock bottom but if when you
love someone it is hard to watch a loved
one hit rock bottom yeah then you feel
like oh man I could have done more but
you know yeah it's just one of those
things where it's just one of those
things you're just gonna [ __ ] it up
you're gonna [ __ ] it up like you're
gonna [ __ ] it up and hopefully she makes
it out I mean there's no right way to
deal with it there's only the textbook
way which is let her deal with it the
way she needs to deal with it and you
know cutting sometimes cutting someone
out of your life is a favor to them and
you know this guy's having a kid or
whatever or has a kid it's like
foreign
yeah I I have a kid and I'm and thinking
about my kid not being able to see my
parents because of that or something
it's just heartbreaking yeah it's tough
yeah that's real challenging man if some
of you if you're trying to wait for
somebody and what exactly was he saying
I mean I heard him but I'm saying he was
saying he's living there to save money
but the mom is drinking a lot yeah
that's how that's when he noticed yes
you're living with her he said she
always uh I Cuts him out because it was
like oh 40 but uh he said she used to
always have a glass of wine he thought
his dad was the Drinker because he would
get hammered on weekends but now when
he's living with her he sees she's
getting hammered every night yeah yeah
that's challenging man
yeah and I think it's hard for him I
don't know if it's hard or easy for a
mother to hear something from her son
that's like that you know I think
I mean some other person to tell her
it's the person to tell her that's yeah
that's for sure well but but the thing
too is like this guy has trying to he's
trying to control his own life too yeah
so he's trying to be like I'm having a
kid I'm trying to save money I have my
woman we're trying to do this thing and
then there's this Albatross there's this
thing here that's like what do I do this
little thirst Bear yeah what do I do and
so he's like doesn't know what to do
because whatever Choice he makes he's
gonna feel shitty yeah yeah and that's
the that's what's hard yeah yeah yeah
that's what's hard yeah raising your kid
raising Calvin it's like you're gonna
[ __ ] up you're gonna [ __ ] up but you
don't want this outside force it's also
[ __ ] up right right you know what I
mean so then you have to make some hard
choice between this the person you love
that you're responsible for and this
other person that you would love dearly
it's a hard Choice it's difficult I
would suggest therapy uh honestly do we
know if we think the mother is an
alcoholic or is she just going through
some that's the kind of the tough part
it's like yeah yeah you can't convince
somebody that they have a problem yeah
you have to it is tough waiting for
somebody to hit rock bottom you know if
that's what you're waiting for I got a
family member I'm waiting for in here
it's like what can you do you can only
do so much
you talk to them but then sometimes
people get in such a bad way they lash
out at you all the time for no reason
where it's like you can't even really
talk to him yeah because at that point
yeah you're just kind of supporting them
in these really bad spaces and you're
not even talking to that right you know
what I mean it's like they're
sleepwalking and they've been gone
sometimes for years the actual person
you knew well another
super difficult to deal with when you're
dealing with an alcoholic is is that you
have to be so patient because if you say
somebody's drunk and they [ __ ] up they
do some [ __ ] you can't immediately be
like yo you know you're doing this thing
because they can't even they can't even
understand so you got to wait a week
until maybe they're sober and then you
got to be like hey you know this
happened yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you
know and so at a certain point you got
to go like your situation you're in
you're like I don't have time for this
because I have my kid that I got to keep
safe and so this guy my suggestion is
like you you may not be able to save
this money yeah you need you need to
take your woman and you need to get your
own place because you are now making
yourself unhappy you're watching this
thing happen to your mom and you can't
do anything about it and so you need to
have a comfortable space of your own so
you can escape to that that is yours
that you have control of because it's
just gonna drive you crazy and you know
and then it's probably hard to leave
because then you don't want to be like
away from it maybe in a way I don't know
I don't know how far away I'm not saying
there's no right or wrong way because
then you end up then you end up enabling
the behavior and I've been in this
situation my per the person that's in my
life
is now finally in a good rehab got their
life together but it's like but it took
me having to be like
but that's the hardest thing to do it's
easy to say but hard to do and you don't
notice it until you're out of it when
you go damn I should have done that
before but I didn't have it in me to do
it yeah next position he's in right now
he don't have it in him to do it yeah
man it's tough I feel for your mother
man and yeah it's tough to know what to
suggest you know you could try to take
her to a meeting or introduce her to
somebody that knows about going to
meetings but it's hard to yeah it's hard
to convince somebody if they're not
trying to convince themselves yeah and
some people don't always like just [ __ ]
up where they hit a bottom like if his
mom's retired she could drink at home
every night and really nothing would
happen right and it would just be like
this slow right right so he might have
to say like if he doesn't like the
drinking like you can't see the kids
unless you yeah right
she could drink forever right or and she
could it could be stressed that they're
there who know it also there could be
other things to it I don't know it's
hard to know what's going on we're
seeing well one thing we do know is this
guy doesn't like it right so if he don't
like it you need to change your
situation that's a great point there you
go that's a great good advice anyway
hold on a second yeah we got real
serious yeah I know anyway anyway I have
tour dates chrisley.com Chris I got one
of your 17 30. yeah
he's crying talking to him later he's
[ __ ] crying on the podcast again what
are we gonna do
who's this his Port noise that's what I
was gonna say yeah sorry to go back to
back but another heavy issue right who's
making this [ __ ] I thought we fired this
guy already
from Phoenix and I got a king in her
sting I'm sorry uh
sunglasses inside uh Chris I was at your
show last night in Phoenix and uh
sitting directly across from me was some
dude in the front row wearing sunglasses
probably gacked out of his mind on
cocaine but it is what it is so I just
want to get you guys opinion on that um
I know you love video or
[ __ ] driving submission so I thought
I'd hop in my golf cart to get a little
extra credit here this guy Sophie you
know guys gang gang buzz buzz swords are
[ __ ] awesome I love this guy uh yeah
yeah I think doing the cocaine man I
remember getting all coked out one time
and going to
um Dodgers game and I thought every
Mexican guy there was trying to fight me
or stab me
and I remember thinking that for like 20
minutes and I was so paranoid and [ __ ]
and then I poked up oh yeah and I
remember asking my friend I'm like dude
I think every and I don't want to say
Mexican guy but it was Mexican guys it
was like 30 000 Mexican guys in the
upper deck I was like I feel like every
Mexican dude here wants to [ __ ] fight
me or stab me and the guy's like dude
everybody's been yelling that they're
gonna fight us or [ __ ] status
huh I'll leave it in a little bit okay
it was the course it could have been the
code but he is way smarter than me my
buddy I don't think he was here I mean
he was some I think were they gonna
fight you because you were wearing
sunglasses I think somebody was trying
to hurt us yeah but that's outside
outside right right this guy's talking
about sunglasses it's okay if you're
playing a character like or if you're on
a podcast and [ __ ] like being silly I
think yeah inside though if you're going
to grab a coffee and you're just sitting
there quick and you drink it that's fine
but if you're at like a [ __ ] meeting
or something or at a show I mean maybe
you know you'd understand Jack Nicholson
and the [ __ ] Lakers games and [ __ ]
that's fine because it's bright and he's
also a 80 I think you're being a little
defensive about sunglasses inside I
don't think that you should I think
there are times you can do it if you're
75 or above in the at a [ __ ]
basketball game in the front row and
you're rich those are the ones that
cover your whole you know what I mean if
you're no not for Jack Nicholson if
you're even alive you should have one
sunglasses well you should you get to do
with a lot you can then then you get to
put on a fedora you know what I mean
it's this kind of [ __ ] it's a wrap at
that point right you could do whatever
you want show up in a [ __ ] nightgown
it doesn't matter yeah Theo is two weeks
away from a fedora but if you're 30 and
you're at a basketball game or you're
sitting in a meeting with sunglasses on
that's awful for you that's awful for
you it depends on where the meeting is
if the meeting is in a bright spot or if
somebody's parking their truck right in
front of the meeting and they forgot to
turn their headlights off
or if you guys are dealing if somebody
if you just had an optical surgery sure
yes there's always exceptions oh come on
dude but yeah that's what I'm saying
just give this guy a chance what's his
problem
wow look at Jack Nicholson why is this
guy ratting out some other dude that's
at the show well he wasn't specific it's
okay that's what Jack Nicholson was at
the I don't give a [ __ ] state but I
still [ __ ] wow look at that huh unreal
he looks like a po boy sandwich
hey Chris I know I know you're a big NBA
fan yeah you're a big Sports guy but
here's the deal though I'm a fan of
things and I like things and this is a
thing and then also betting I'm in
because you in order to get things you'd
need money and if you like basketball
and you want to make money you gotta use
DraftKings Sports books the official
Sportsman part of the NBA this week new
customers can bet just five dollars on
any team so okay so if you could bet
five dollars what are you gonna win
you're gonna win six dollars dude dude
what you bet five dollars on any team to
win ten dollars one hundred and fifty
dollars in free bets yo what nazos they
got parties DraftKings yeah dude you got
drafted this is a d this is steel dude
it's nuts okay well if you're looking at
so if you're telling me if you're
looking to turn a small bed into a big
payday during the NBA Playoffs you can
do that with DraftKings yep dude same
game parlays you can just do just that
just that create your own parlay by
combining multiple bets like which team
will win total threes made total
rebounds and more and boom you have a
shot at even bigger payout right now all
customers can place the same game parlay
with three or more legs and get a free
BET back up to 25 if one leg doesn't hit
wow download the draftking Sportsbook
app right now use promo code Kats cats
five dollars on any NBA team to win
their game we win like six bucks or what
dude and get 150 in free bets if they
what
150. I like your excitement okay yeah
yeah yeah yeah this promo code Kats only
at draftking Sportsbook minimum age
eligibility restriction Supply C show
notes for details see next page for
directions for disclaimer guys let's
take a breath let's take a break dude
okay I want to talk to you about
hellofresh hello okay fresh dude you get
farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and seasonal
recipes delivered right to your doorstep
it's like it's like you're getting the
best of the restaurant world and the
Homeworld at home skip trips to the
grocery store count on hellofresh to
make home cooking it's home cooking easy
yeah but is it really expensive because
dude I'm stressed dude it's insane it's
so cheap it's ridiculous it's even
cheaper than the grocery store what's up
that's mine in your pocket so you can
buy thick boy merch and all that stuff
and tickets to all our shows like
Philadelphia Mediterranean recipes oh oh
dude have you ever had Mediterranean
food seriously and hello fresh nails
that I've had it it's crazy dude they've
got so many things they've got chefs
that really know how to they they
diversify your dinner menu right what
sees those big recipes with tempura
bowls Garden spinach ricotta ravioli one
pot creamy lemon lemon or a dill chicken
pancakes yeah forget it wow dude over 50
different weekly options you never get
bored whatever diet you're on they got
you covered go to hellofresh.com king16
use the code King 16 for up to 16 free
meals and three free gifts that is
hellofresh.com king16 use the code King
16 for up to 16 free meals and three
free gifts and let me tell you one thing
America's number one meal kick it is but
and let me tell you another reason why
this is good that people don't really
think of because you just think of oh
it's tasty and oh it's good which it is
it is very tasty and good but dude it
saves you time and time is money it's
money dude and here he is here he is
younger here he is after that Peloton I
guess you have to have a beard to send
in a video I guess yeah
what up King and the sting in the wing
this is Brian from New Jersey
for you boys drinking your significant
other's blood like MGK and Megan Fox I
personally am not down for that I'm
getting married in a month and if that
was a requirement I'm not sure I'd be
able to go through with it so I want to
hear what your boys think about that let
me know love the show gang gang buzz
buzz soar nice in Egypt and a lot of
countries they do and tribal countries
also they do a lot of that they do the
drinking of the blood you swap the blood
out uh people sip it out of a like a
little uh goblet it's unhygienic huh I
don't know where those two have been
either I don't know what their situation
is bad news they're 40. she's 40 right
like you're gonna drink a 40 year old's
blood what about [ __ ] like 25 you
know what I mean peppers have been
around that blood's gross dude yeah and
MGK looks like at least that came back
to being straight
but drinking MGK's blood I get it he's
like you know what is it 28 29 yeah is
he I think so 31. yeah but he's also oh
really he's also a touring like artist
so he's just his dirty gross blood yeah
but this tells me that you guys have
never you know maybe went down and
licked your girl's [ __ ] when she was on
her period oh my god I've never done
that dude what are you well are you some
kind of what man it's just not the
accident I didn't know this was the
patreon episode
unbelievable with this comes out red as
[ __ ] yeah you've never you come out
reddish
you may get a little you know he puts
the head
you could drink a pint of blood before
you get sick
so you well yeah no I don't think going
down on someone when they're bleeding
that that's very it's very Roman I feel
like it's very uh yeah well you're
pretty stationary Roman
we gotta we gotta hit the you gotta hit
the groaner sometimes oh you gotta hit
the ground graphic that goes oof
um no but look man what is the guys what
did he say about it yeah he's just like
should you drink other people's blood is
it cool it's something it's honestly
it's obviously it's a thing for us it's
you know nobody drinks other people's
blood and he doesn't tell people about
it it's all pretense hey I drank her
blood bro I'm [ __ ] badass all I'm
saying is you've never like maybe not on
purpose but I've this has happened to me
you know okay well that's different you
know I have a fingering it's different
don't do the thing with your tongue
disgusting disgusting what's wrong with
you dog yeah don't go you know what I
mean damn dog you gotta make noises
the the buzzing noise helps to you know
what I mean I don't you don't make any
noises when you eat your girls when you
just down there like I go like this hmm
yeah oh interesting while you're alone I
like hold music on my phone
you you play now do you hold it up like
this while you're down there like this
yeah
in the middle of it it's like thank you
for holding this is Jen from Ikea just a
second honey yeah I ordered a uh
she's almost done
man I think but I will say this and
there were times when it was a rite of
passage if you got married you took a
sip out of each other's blood it was a
it was like a thing I'm gonna take this
person into my body I'm gonna take it in
Arkansas huh and look it up drink it you
guys have 70 computers I just looked it
up and said there's thousands of people
in the US that drink each other's blood
that means it's not good thousands
thousands
talk to me when it's a million
it's pretense [ __ ] it's a lot
thousands is a lot of thousands of
people in here we couldn't even close
the door
small room yeah this why would you have
a thousand people come here all right
what's this guy got what a weird bed set
up
once you have a bed on the floor look
like every other ski bag on here wow all
right what do you have for us what's up
Pete Davidson my name is Tyler and I'm
enough here's all now I'm from
Newfoundland and I got a king or thing
at Hometown traditions
um when you visit Newfoundland for the
first time uh you gotta get screeched in
it's it's customary
um this is where like an old man in a
yellow raincoat presents you a shot of
uh Screech and a uh frozen fish
um
and you gotta kiss it on the lips
uh I know it sounds bad but you know
you're kind of a [ __ ] if you don't do
it
um yeah King and her staying at her wing
it uh shout out to uh Chris though
um next time at the Log Cabin meeting
can I open up with my hot five I got a
really good five minutes thanks
uh uh I don't understand I don't know
what is what the [ __ ] did he just say
UPS yeah this guy's give him a fish and
and he's got a bed on the side of his
bed which is weird and he has like like
glasses of a 78 year old man I don't so
a guy gave him a fish in new
Newfoundland this car gets reached in oh
uh you have to watch uh Saved by the
Bell like the first season of Saved by
the bells how you get screeched in
right so you can't have a growner [ __ ]
all y'all no you have a groaner it's
nice well look the thing is the man said
you gotta kiss the fish to get into the
town or something so so we're going back
to eating [ __ ] I get it oh God there's
two groaners
let me tell you something right now any
tradition is bad do you know how many
[ __ ] no you know how many [ __ ]
Wars have started just because of
tradition tradition is always bad
because times change
the entire religion again no you can
have a tradition for five years and then
make a new tradition because at times
change no but times change no matter
what they don't have nothing to do with
it think about it think about all the
Traditions you would miss out on dude uh
having slaves go ahead a traditional
Pastime
Halloween Christmas going to the mall
when you're a teenager yeah but that's
not a tradition
um
having a picnic with your family let's
just [ __ ] people do that's a chicken
queue yeah
uh square dancing class when you're in
high school don't I met this was
concentration yeah what's a chicken
queue can you look it up uh it'd be like
uh it was a fundraiser and they would
just smoke a ton of chicken and you'd
get like a seven dollar plate that had
baked beans and smoked chicken and the
money would go to the church chicken
Cube okay
no no Halloween's a holiday [ __ ]
Christmas a holiday shirts
we're gonna talk about kissing fish to
[ __ ] indoctrinate someone in
Newfoundland that's [ __ ] horseshit
but welcome to town bug this is not
everybody else has done to be in town
well how about just say welcome to town
that's fine
the tradition of talking greeting
someone is good welcome to town thank
you very much I'm now part of this town
that's the whole tradition bring a
bagpipe whatever but that's [ __ ] too
much but a bagpipe would be a tradition
I mean what I'm saying I'm making New
Traditions Chris I don't know you don't
like the joy of it you think no I don't
like to drive kissing a fish a dead fish
well it's not about the fish so much as
about the tradition right the tradition
is kissing the dead fish no but the the
tradition really just represents the
camaraderie of that town no matter what
it is if that town doesn't have
camaraderie without kissing a fish
foreign
dude some families have tradition you
know there's a lot of different families
have different tradition what they wear
different your family have Traditions
mine yeah they're so annoying yeah my
dad's like every every Christmas uh
every Christmas night we read that
[ __ ] one where the kids on the train
and can't hear the Bell oh Polar Express
and I'm like dude I'm 40 now that was
awesome up until I was 12. yeah and he
still wants to do it yeah
your dad come on I thought I know when
I'm 75 do it on Calvin's that age I'm
gonna be doing two I know I get it's
going to be who it is for him you know
what I didn't realize he'll have long
dumb hair too
because tradition if yeah man I think
you gotta have some good traditions
all right well wait do we have any King
in the sting traditions
yeah you do you have like the freaking
just being here
no there's all different gifts yeah you
have a bunch of traditions you do here
that's true we have white elephant gift
swap we used to have these buzzers we're
kind of a thing yeah dress up on
Halloween yeah tradition and Christmas
dresses March for people's birthdays
boom joint birthdays yeah
so be in here
eating hot food
you're getting hot food is definitely
not a tradition
I mean super super spicy food yeah and
this guy's got one
can you turn to can you turn the light
down we can still see him
what's happening guys is Xander from
glasgows Glasgow wow
super DJ in the city center
because I can't be [ __ ] interested to
enjoy myself
okay I'm just going to get in your
opinion on DJing as a joke as a real and
respectable job or not
I'm not all that sure that it is
I'll leave the cash
hey
yeah you can't stay away I'm not sure
what anyway it is but we'll go for that
yeah gang gang buzz buzz sword
I like how he didn't have an accent when
he said that sure it's kind of like
Asian people at a karaoke place yeah if
he's you know what I mean yeah we didn't
start the fire no but it's like they
sing in like perfect English when they
talk you don't know what's going on
that's because he hears us saying it
he's just imitating us saying oh yep but
DJing is a real job if podcasting is a
real job yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean
there's different levels of DJing and
difficult difficulty of DJing you know
there's some guys that are out there
[ __ ] actually doing the [ __ ] and then
somebody's out there that go boom all
right let's do this let's just let the
ship play yeah they're doing this right
and that's a kind of a party guy but
like they make the most no they make
money if you're [ __ ] willing to pay
you know what I mean what's the guy
what's the what's one of those guys
Steve Aoki yeah Steve Aoki Diplo they
make music though
yeah yeah but that's not the point right
that's to say just like you do comedy it
has nothing to do so is he talking about
right true okay so is he talking about
like uh
it's a job yeah that's what I'm saying
look man I'll tell you this we had a
felon our town named John was his name
and he was the DJ dude there's Diplo
right there on this past weekend if you
ever enjoy that beautiful show but what
I'm saying is we had a fellow named John
was his name John L and he was our DJ he
DJ'd it all wedding funeral school dance
High School dance
um
well whatever he did he was a man right
so he became like this kind of like uh
he almost became an encyclopedia of
things that had happened in the town you
know so there's a lot of value in that
you know because you'd be like oh Play
the song you played it this thing yeah
yeah yeah yeah so he kind of was a
tradition yeah this music man and uh and
he also was dating half the girls that
were at all the events DJs are swimming
it right they swim in it dude DJ's just
swimming it they're the new but when was
this this was let me see probably 90s
imagine that guy now he'd be dead I mean
he'd be that if he was doing it if he
was swimming back then he'd be swimming
now he'd be he would drown dude there's
I mean DJ's kid I mean it was John
ellsworld music that was his company
John Ells loud music LLC
is that a groin or is that real it's
just that's just we call that a Theo oh
that's uh I mean I went to probably 60
dances that he did 60 Tootsie Roll yeah
what was your go-to move when you're out
on the Dance Floor oh my thing would be
oh uh close your eyes I got you
something if I was Dan oh dancer dance
what was your dance uh what would you do
out there what was it close your eyes I
got you something
that was for the girls yeah I would say
close your eyes that sounds very creepy
what you put your dick in their mouth
like what do you do you're disgusting
dude okay you made the sound I would say
put your hand out then you put your dick
in your hand huh then you put your dick
in your hand then I would give him a
little smooch on them
on the uh face on that uh so you said
close your eyes and get an unconsensual
kiss from you put your hand down it
wasn't it was if you knew there was it
was a pack right there was an
understanding yeah yeah until later she
was like and then he kissed me and I
didn't even ask him yeah and if
something on my girl would be like hey
uh yeah I'm not that's not my advice
how you danced what was your dance move
oh I did a lot of different type of uh
James Brown type of stuff I was more
like hips and legs oh wow really that
Tick Tock a little bit of that Elvis
Presley okay I use my whole body what
about you
[Applause]
man and we had square dancing too I
remember in uh school brother
we had to take square dance in class
that was part of your electorates no
it's just part of growing up I think
there was three years of square dancing
did you guys have it square dancing no
no you took three years of square
dancing in high school no it's pretty
much a year and you know it you know
yeah
I'm at square dancing AP
e if you were on the Swarm team we had
they had like a the whole team it was
swarm it was like square dancing swarm
it was like the bit like the
DeAndre you know without the drugs or
somebody it was like the
you know Willie galtz of square dance
and it was people like a square dance
like that could really screwed like a
job that's their job or they go they win
oh it was the best they only show about
it but they had squared I mean we had
three yeah we had three three years we
had to do square dancing you know I
don't think we're gonna do it yeah Jesus
Christ it was an elective right I mean
it wasn't like no it was like so instead
of p square dance and it was twice a
week and we had square dance oh okay
well PE okay at least it's active but
that's hilarious well yeah the music
just
like the real square dancing it's about
I think it was bring your partner pull
out your dick and stick it okay yeah
okay oh yeah that's true yeah it was
like uh well they had the caller you
know and sometimes you would even get a
call like on certain holiday or around
holiday in Spring especially to get a
caller and they're a real caller ooh so
like so I wonder if that's still a thing
is that like being a DJ a square dance
caller
I don't know it's probably like an
original DJ yeah
that's it
and sometimes you would get crossed up
finally with a girl you liked and you
were just so excited you have to go get
some water that's nice why because you
were nervous yeah
why not what else you think it'll be
just I wouldn't miss a woman because of
sheer thirst maybe nerves
God I remember that this guy's got one
okay
what's up guys I'm Joe from Indianapolis
big fan of you all have a king or sting
it amen for you
um inspired by a friend of mine who may
be a bigger fan than me hit me up to all
you guys loves all you guys pray so much
that his girlfriend now wife thought he
was the funniest guy in the world until
she started listening to your podcast
didn't realize that's where all the
jokes come from me
um but me this is something he does that
I make fun of him for all the time I
think it's the girliest [ __ ] in the
world it's
crossing your legs
above your knee oh no that's they got to
do that that's King [ __ ] that's King
[ __ ]
there's actually footage of the uh
Burger King guy doing it that's King
[ __ ] did you do that [ __ ] to be so
comfortable like this that's King [ __ ]
dude it's not a real king though the
Burger King but if you do this just a
title if you do this some people this is
the crazy thing that I say is when
people do
this like they do music like a cricket
like on the couch or just up suspended
an air just like this they just sit like
that
can you believe a qriket does this this
is
thinking how crazy they are yeah it's
just mating [ __ ]
that's what makes that noise right
imagine you just yeah
yeah they're playing basically back that
thing up every time they do it so who
does that kind of [ __ ] imagine
it's been okay yeah
oh yeah right here oh yeah that's a
cricket DJ right here are you ready to
get this party started
oh yeah yeah that has to be the picture
for the episode yeah yeah 100 so but
that's crazy to have your own music your
own say you're the dj right there and
it's in your quads that's nice so you're
that's like Eric when he drives home
just singing the [ __ ] you sing [ __ ] by
yourself yeah that's how it sounds I
have I play karaoke in my car pretty lit
actually you know on the screen the
words come up you know what I mean I'm
just like Unbreak My Heart say you love
me again
here's what I will say to this man is uh
I think it's okay to put your legs like
that I used to think I had to sit a
certain comfortable way you know and
it's better for your back it's silly
yeah it makes sense like I remember when
I was like 16 I would just sit like this
you know I thought that that's how just
guys were supposed to sit up straight
though you know that yeah but not like
you're trying gonna fight everybody like
feel sits like this all the time what
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah what's up
[ __ ] what fool yeah you just
stay ready what'd you say about whites
but you gotta do this or sit up straight
or dude [ __ ] rock it man because that
shows you're comfortable enough to be
like yeah I know people think that when
you sit like that you got a small dick
but I don't have a small dick dude yeah
it feels like you're about to say
something poignant you know well that's
when you sit like this and you go you
can't do I don't have your hands here
that's what you can't do I don't think
oh I like it I will sit like this all
day long you have your hands here then
you go uh this is this is you guys have
seen this this is therapy [ __ ] yes the
therapist goes like this so Chris tell
us tell us about your dad tell us about
why you whatever and then you go like
this and a bird comes and lands on your
finger that's what this is King [ __ ]
that's in a long way from that though
you know what I mean yeah it goes a long
way from now but yeah I think give your
guy or don't give him a hard time
because I even seen people that don't
have any legs and they will take one of
their prosthetic legs and put it up on
the other one like that wow
that's a bit you hang around with a lot
of like amputees right yeah just to be
honest yeah that's in his cult right
there amps they call them first of all
and uh they call them amps a lot of
amputees do what up hello amps fellow
amps or my amps that's not a slur it
will be it will be it will be it will
huh it will be put up my amps They Don't
Clap because they have no hands
are y'all out here let me know y'all
here let me know y'all can do it like
this where my abs at I'm just gonna
trust you're here
I don't hear anything but now that I
realize what I asked I'm just gonna
trust that you're all here let's get
down to business
you're the one guy out there that you
you're like
okay
he slaps himself
I'm not
I'm a big fan especially especially of
Theo Von and crystalia
um
Eric's feelings here smoking on your
lunch break can't get her sting it okay
I do live in an illegal state but I'd be
working with dogs they'd be irritating
the [ __ ] out of me I'm not gonna lie
I don't think I could make it through
the day without it smoking I just wanted
your guys's opinion well what do you
mean illegal
if there was 20 people here yeah then
you could call out too okay yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay so you can call out
too but when it's only four yeah three
regular hosts and then like I don't even
know what you know you don't call out
too but but just in in you in her
defense and your defense she did not
know you're here yeah so maybe she's
like I would have said Eric but I don't
even know if he's there maybe she just
[ __ ] hates Brendan yeah that's what
I'm saying I'm just trying to help you
he's not here he probably won't listen
to this so she really just said [ __ ] you
Brandon that's what she just said
um I don't know dude uh yeah I think uh
I I think it's stupid that weed isn't
really illegal anywhere you know if
you're gonna be responsible about it she
looks like she's responsible you just do
it on your smoke break I mean that being
said if you do work at a company the
company doesn't want you high so right
it might be legal to do or it might be
illegal to do I think that that's stupid
you should still do it anyway because
it's just weed but if you're at work
it's a little [ __ ] as Brenda would
say dicey because you wouldn't
necessarily want to oh by the way too
it's like when you're at a casino and
they allow smoking yeah I [ __ ] hate
that like not everybody's because they
don't want you to go outside that's why
I know but it's like you know what I
always do around my crap table people
are smoking I fart
oh dude I'm talking about this I'm
talking about like I'm I'm talking about
oh yes I want them to hear yeah I want
[ __ ] to look at me like did you
just fart yeah [ __ ] cause y'all smoking
yeah so how about saying smell that
smell it you're lucky I didn't [ __ ]
you're lucky that's God's cigarette baby
yeah yeah yeah yeah dude that's great
that's my last pipe that's great that's
great dude yeah you know what dude
you're one of my guys
huge man so much smoke and you just yeah
now we're even yeah right so there's a
Level Playing Field yeah you don't like
that smell that's what I don't like yeah
yeah okay and my fart ain't gonna cause
cancer there's no there's no such thing
as called right second hand fart yeah
nobody ever talks about secondhand fart
right which is the only yeah which is I
think it's V people get secondhand fart
all the time because that's how people
know somebody farted right but there's
no like is it causing it look it up
secondhand farting information team
there'll be a commercial in a few years
my husband died of secondhand farting I
left it under the sheets every morning
he would get up and Dutch oven his ass
and now he's not around but there's like
a class action lawsuit in 20 years have
you have you been farted near yeah and
now she farts out of the side of her
[ __ ] because it she had the surgery
bro the colostomy bag no she farts at
the same you know how people smoke out
of the phone right she farts she shits
out of the side like a collage and her
voice still goes I don't know why I'm
talking like this do you all do farts in
y'all's marriage or not oh yeah yeah
what are you talking about how far no
the problem is that she farts that's the
problem you think that's a problem yeah
when you get close to a girl that's not
gonna win a girl fart when a guy farts
it's manly when a girl farts it's manly
yeah so it's a bit yeah it's it's
disconcerting wait wait did not say
secondhand fart smell could be good for
you yeah it could uh I'm helping you
[ __ ] prevent heart disease and
kidney failure but damn the man said uh
what does he saying the cigarette smoke
no she was saying that uh oh look first
of all a launch yeah if launch might for
some people weed is lunch they don't
even eat all they do is smoke weed and
they're gonna probably die soon so some
people they want to just smoke man and
they want to just get that that
bronchial brunch baby that lunch for
your lungs son that's what they want
that weed bronchial brunch that's gonna
be the name of your weed company you'll
see some brothers just have a [ __ ]
joint for breakfast bro and they [ __ ]
roll on and they said I know what the
skinny dude some skinny dudes do that
though yeah bro but the thing is it's
where you do it like juice don't be
doing smoke and [ __ ] where other people
are there not everybody's in but he's
just talking about doing it at lunch and
then going back to work hot and you've
got to be yeah but you got to be wild if
you're working around a bunch of dogs
secondhand dogs third hand dogs to be
getting high and going around a bunch of
it depends on where you are if you're in
like uh you know Narragansett or
somewhere where
one time I would like a video submission
of like it's like her boss yeah and
she's like hey yeah I'm a fan of King of
the sting and I saw one of my employees
getting high at lunch and so I fired her
so this is just like a cautionary tale
for people out there sending in
submissions of like drinking and driving
right right right right right you know
what I mean like drinking people's blood
drinking people's blood maybe we need to
[ __ ] do that we need a PSA yeah man
yeah I know hi are you doing something
really stupid uh don't send that in as a
video if you're doing it at work yeah
yeah but the big question for this is
you build a house somebody who doesn't
build houses
and that was from the patreon that was
from the patreon sign up right now to go
check it out patreon.com cats plus the
biggest question is it seems like
overall is that this man uh sorry this
young lady yeah you said that like it
was so long ago because it's always 20
minutes was it it was in the nose rings
the problem is that a lot of people if
if you don't smoke you don't get that
break if you're just standing around
having a little whipped cream or a
little cut of pie or something at work
they'll get on your ass but if you want
to go outside and have a cigarette you
get that extra time very interesting
point there's always been an issue with
smokers and non-smokers at restaurants
like why do they get to go out I want a
pie break right yeah yeah I want six
minutes to go sit outside by the
dumpster right and just have a snack and
think or just even how about think yeah
can I do can I have my think break yeah
no can I go smoke you got it wait are
you waiting I don't think that's real
are you telling me that
other than your scheduled 10 minute
break you get an extra small bro we're
joking you need that no well mostly we
didn't have no 10-minute break we just
said hey can I go have a smoke break and
so at a certain point the night at the
restaurant you go get a smoke break
hey I just want to go have a break and
you didn't smoke you'd have to go hide
in the [ __ ] and eat a piece of power
you know the best way to eat pie
honestly while you're [ __ ] Well we'd
stay in there we didn't [ __ ] and eat wow
this [ __ ] and eating at the same
time is insane you say that forever it
never stops you just keep eating and
[ __ ] no because that would mess with
your whole smell thing like yeah no [ __ ]
yeah
oh [ __ ] dude bro don't don't freaking
come down on them because he don't know
what's happening no okay okay so yeah I
don't know what's happening with you
guys yeah you've got some weird stuff
going on yeah he has whipped cream
breaks like I don't know where the [ __ ]
he's eating damn blood labia
both of you guys you [ __ ] with blood
all over your face being like to the
bathroom and he's eating pie on the
[ __ ] yeah are you done I need to wash
my face
dude the two [ __ ] the worst roommates
never
mind Chris is just on the couch like
this yeah yeah what are you guys doing
yeah yeah yeah I hope it's not fun
and the Lord doesn't exist yeah he might
he might
he's coming around
what up King of this thing in the wing
this is Zach from Charlotte North
Carolina and I got a king it or sting it
for you
wearing traditionally feminine things
where clothing items or jewelry as a
straight guy
I coach High School baseball so I hear
it all the time I'm sure they make fun
of it yeah I hear that they make fun of
it all the time the fact that I wear
this butterfly necklace but I think the
fact that most straight guys wouldn't
wear a butterfly necklace is the reason
I should wear a butterfly necklace
um yeah but so I guess that's a
statement if you want to call it it's a
statement yeah anyway yeah can't
understand it
um big fan of all of you gang gang buzz
buzz I think that's cool
um that is actually pretty feminine I
mean that that butterfly it's like pink
yeah but he's also uh like uh he's an
attractive guy yeah right so he's
getting away with all kind of [ __ ] yeah
you get what I'm saying yeah like like
it's not like it's not like me saying
that fair point you know I mean if I got
a butterfly like what yeah think of my
butterfly things
but this guy's like really attractive so
you know there's no rules for a guy that
looks like that they're not they're not
teasing him because he has a butterfly
next and they're teasing him because
he's got like [ __ ] you know right
because he's a good looking dude if he
can get it so what would they tease you
about then say again what would they
tease you about it'd be different that's
what he's saying I don't know and it's a
good recognition
and I'm sitting here and then they used
to call me that'd be a good wreck that's
a good recognition what you're doing but
because because the problem with this
guy is if you put on a wig he would
still be beautifully let's just be
honest so he can be both man and woman
he got an androgynous sort of like and
that's called that's not a luxury yeah
so what is he talking about uh he just
do swimming in [ __ ] for sure maybe I
mean he should look you want to do it do
it it's not like he's exactly [ __ ]
Jared Leto over there carrying his head
doing something outlandish but he can
always do it if he carried his [ __ ] a
mannequin head of his at the [ __ ]
softball game and he just had his head
holding his head making this one do it
but he can get it that's what we're
playing today guys a double header
this guy could be easily yeah this dude
is too he's too good looking he could be
man or woman yeah yeah so it's okay I
like what I'm saying is right he could
wear fishnet he could wear a choke
they're not teasing him because it's
feminine they're teasing him because he
can get away with it right wow very
interesting dude I I like your analysis
of this Eric yeah I really like your
announcement puts that [ __ ] on people
and be like damn who's this little
pudding pop over here you know here we
go everybody yeah no I'm just saying
who's this little nature Channel [ __ ]
Bear yeah okay yeah two examples are
good you shoot him put him down okay I
think that we we've got fired up [ __ ]
we've established get the flame thrower
Char him up right
yeah who want that grilled biscuit [ __ ]
him and Chara what's the next one that's
all we got we're stuck
well crystalia.com I will be in Atlanta
Boston Denver I will be in uh a bunch of
different places Jacksonville Savannah
Georgia amazing places so go check uh I
got uh chrysalia.com Cheyenne Wyoming
and I am at riffing with Griffin so
check me out there check out my podcast
too and you know I had my tour dates are
I haven't put the new ones up yet
because I don't even know when this is
coming out amen baby and I'll be
actually coming up uh in Albuquerque New
Mexico on May 16th or May 18th Midland
Texas Midland Texas Lubbock Texas Dallas
Texas those are all in May Savannah
Savannah Georgia Augusta Georgia
Montgomery Alabama and Columbus Georgia
those are all Hollywood
Florida just look at it guys you don't
gotta fight about it nah just because I
forget and then they pull his up and
then I'm like ah [ __ ] but you know
theovan.com tour and thank you guys so
much for the support baby and support
Brendan check out his uh
his friend is not here so check out his
uh special guys oh yeah check out
Brendan oh Washington DC that one too
I'll be there Oakland Stockton you know
interesting
all right well dude tour buddies these
are more Bros his places are more bougie
than your places well I do have Stockton
and Oakland there if I make it on a live
yeah that's true yeah people like people
are in my comments Theo's tours for like
the the people you know what I'm saying
Glasgow
yeah mine are for
the cult the exclusive cult yeah you
can't get in you can't get in unless you
guys can get tickets
you just made everybody
all right you guys take care of
yourselves God bless everybody Dude
Perfect show good timing
it's the king and the sting back up in
this thing
[Music]
how many times I gotta make this song
Wait I get the gist
[Music]
[Music]